[Music]
[Applause]
welcome the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm up an hour oh holy [ __ ] we're
all here welcome back ladies and
gentlemen here we are at the scum and
villainy Cantina in Hollywood California
on Hollywood Boulevard please put your
hands together so the folks at home know
you're real quick story you know we put
the show up on YouTube later on and
stuff after we're done them and somebody
had tweeted at me like hey man [ __ ]
you didn't do the you know tell the
people at home is clap your hands so
they know you're real on the episode and
I was like [ __ ] it I of course I did I
do it like every [ __ ] time and then I
was like wait you're stoned maybe you
didn't [ __ ] do it so I went back to
watch it and it wasn't there all sudden
the show just starts with us [ __ ]
talking and [ __ ] so I reached out to the
fine proprietor this establishment who
was also in charge of the video that's
JC and I was like what [ __ ] do you
always cut it and [ __ ] and apparently
there were some audio issues so they
lost that part but just to assure folks
at home I wasn't [ __ ] lying we're
real like doubt me piece of [ __ ] good
god it's a little cute thing to do at
the beginning of the show but then
somebody noticed when it wasn't there
though like hey man are they real or is
it [ __ ] it's how I know I'm not
dreaming alright so since we last
convened to do the show previously on a
fat man bein thank you yeah well so many
things have happened but not like enough
in my real life I was coming here going
what the [ __ ] has happened and all
that's happening [ __ ] I can't [ __ ]
fully reveal but I can say this I we've
continued to work on that thing we were
talking about last week which now the
internet has started playing guessing
games on was very fun and nobody's
gotten it yet I you know what I'm saying
I noticed that too and it kind of
irritated me where I'm like you don't
think we're [ __ ] good enough for that
you don't throw that into the pile what
they do a Captain Planet like we're not
doing Captain Planet
it just got crossed off the list so I've
been I've been knee-deep in that and
this weekend like I you know I'm I smoke
this incredible [ __ ] weed that's
nowhere else in the [ __ ] world and
sat down to row right that's how long it
took you and that's how good it was when
I sat down to write I had already
written mark it was done it was talking
about some Stephen King levels vance
elves wrote my ship
so I [ __ ] it's it's incredible weed
that also like it keeps you sharply
focused so I was like boom boom boom and
so I wound up working on this thing and
writing an outline a pretty like
comprehensive outline for the first half
of the thing that we're working on and
then next I'll write the same kind of
thing for the back half but we started
meeting about that on Monday and we're
meeting about that one more time before
we start portioning it off and everybody
starts riding this things moving fast
but so ever it is yeah mystery so in
doing that I was so [ __ ] like I'd
never done it before I'm not I don't
write with others and not where I'm like
[ __ ] others but I've just you know
independent film indie I'm usually by
myself alone what Batman so I never
really had a writers room experience
this has been kind of my first and
nominally I'm in charge so that just
means you have to do [ __ ] like that
administrative stuff like hey we need to
see like give me they told me give me
two pages on the thing we're doing like
you know one for one and one for their
one for one half one for them and I
couldn't do it that way so it's like let
me just write everything that we've all
discussed into like one piece so that
we're all kind of on the same page and I
would I handed
and I was so [ __ ] scared like because
again my career is not based on like
somebody saying yes or no it's just like
oh we're gonna do this thing and figure
it out later on and show but when you
work for somebody else there's someone
to disappoint other than the critics and
the audience and so it isn't pens and
checkbook
yeah and they might be like you're
[ __ ] fired so I was like ah [ __ ] I
got to hand this in and I'm nervous
about hand and attending stuff because
it was way longer than was asked for and
the [ __ ] you know I was like did it
work the good news is it went over
[ __ ] huge but it went to the point
where people are like everybody should
do this on every [ __ ] TV show and I
was like oh I did too much [ __ ] yeah
like cuz now they there's a lebar you
know now you can let them down now
there's like the cab Smith Clause and
like [ __ ] on oranges a new
black eye like we got to do what because
of who yeah can we get that weed because
we can't just do that that we'd help so
I did well I'll do it for the for the
other half of the thing we're working on
and stuff but it was incredibly awful
but that's all I've been doing since we
last spoke that and finishing up Jay and
Silent Bob reboot we've been doing all
the last bit of ADR thank you ATR don't
you haven't seen it yet it could be [ __ ]
months from now you might be like why
did we support it I love it I said
before like it's in this weird you know
he always like to be a I'm Pro I always
like to [ __ ] say that to the kid and
[ __ ] like not in a condescending way but
like at the end of the movie Harley was
bawling [ __ ] look oh my god cuz the
birds like camp and [ __ ] and it should
be that's the way making a movie should
be like oh my god we just got away with
something this was fun and when it's
over it should feel like oh my god
you're my best friend in the world I
can't [ __ ] live with that and then
you go back to your normal life that's
what like going to camp was I never went
but that's what it seemed like on
meatballs so so for you know it should
always be like that so at the end of the
movie
was real [ __ ] emotional and [ __ ] and
I'm like oh come on kids she's like why
are you crying I was like because you
know I believe me I love this more than
anybody else just think of all the
trouble I went to bring all these people
together and tell this goofy story I
said but a pro knows how to walk away
and [ __ ] like that you know she's just
like [ __ ] you silent bill I like to
maintain an air of reserve after a
quarter century in the business of like
you know I started as this is who I am
and that's how I introduced myself to
people through those movies now I could
do it through podcast now I could I
could better represent myself just
standing here talking then spending a
bunch of money to tell you a story and
have people be like I think I know his
character like it's cheaper for me to be
like I'll tell you about my [ __ ]
character you know so I've been able to
kind of grow it over time and I didn't I
I thought that I didn't fetishize movie
make it as much as I did when I was a
kid because then it was my only means of
communication it was like this is how
they're gonna know what I'm thinking and
feeling now I could do that a number of
ways so I felt like a professional
reserved from it or maybe I felt that
because the last movie was yo goes there
some people like you saw and I'm like
well I'm professionally reserved from
that so thank you I couldn't handle that
sort of thing
but I'm at the stage now with Jay and
Silent Bob reboot where like I
absolutely [ __ ] love it and like it's
gonna hurt when other people don't agree
with me and I'm a pro like I should I
understand that not everyone will agree
with me but I loved it so much that like
I have to get past this phase of like
why wouldn't somebody like that you know
what I'm saying
like a real proud parent like oh my god
[ __ ] like Kevin's the bet the way my
mother talks about me is the way I talk
about this movie man just all pride and
[ __ ] I absolutely love it so we've been
coming to a close with it I've seen like
almost the last visual effects Armand
and the folks that aren't queer that do
all the visual effects for most of the
CW shows you watch I think they do
Titans I don't know if they they might
actually do Krypton as well I'm not sure
I don't want to give him credit that it
didn't it but they do everything else
they do flash Supergirl that's how I
grew to work with them we had them do
our special effects so
the I don't want to spoil but like well
last time we made Jay and Silent Bob
strike back we built a blunt cave-in in
on the stage at CBS Radford and you had
to build it it was paper mache and [ __ ]
but like you walked in here like who's
[ __ ] okay this like what a [ __ ]
dumb idea so we didn't have to do that
in Jay and Silent Bob reboot because you
you wouldn't build something like that
anymore you'd build the pieces that you
interact with and then the rest goes to
CG right so our blunt cave this time
around was a you know structure that the
production designer built that we could
stand on in Iraq to it but the right we
were just surrounded by [ __ ] green it
was like [ __ ] endgame except with not
all none of the money none of the talent
but like to say when you watch there
behind the scenes I was a cop [ __ ] we
did that for it for a day on our [ __ ]
movie they did it for three years or
whatever [ __ ] to make what they made so
that means somebody got Phil in the
background and so I'd worked with Arman
on my episodes Arman kind of responsible
for getting in getting me into those
shows because like he created King shark
he was the guy his team built King shark
and that was the thing that made Jason
Mewes call me and be like holy [ __ ] you
got to watch flash King sharks on and I
was like [ __ ] king shark who would
bother and I turn I saw it on I could
eat it's too late to watch I saw it on
Twitter and I was like holy [ __ ]
like they cracked the code of king shark
like you know yeah no it looks so much
better than it had any right to because
it's such a dopey concept and [ __ ] but
that got me into the show I was like I'm
gonna watch this show they could make
King shark work [ __ ] this show might
be good so I fell in love with that and
fell in love a super girl and stuff
wound up with directing those shows so
Armen was kind of my way in and stuff so
we've worked together on my episodes but
he always said he's going if you ever
doing James Allen Bob that sequel you
keep promising he's gonna [ __ ] let us
get first crack at doing the visual
effects so they did and they've been
doing a tremendous job and they built me
the most beautiful spacious expensive
looking
blunt cave something that this movie
does not [ __ ] deserve like her for
like for a good few minutes in the movie
it looks so expensive you know and then
it goes back to Kevin Smith movie but it
was such a [ __ ] thrill so I've seen
now they've delivered almost every shot
there's like two shots that they're
tweaking and finishing but all the
visual effect shots are done in the
movie and this is this is not bragging
and this is not saying this makes me a
better filmmaker by any stretch of the
imagination for the layman this is just
to show you how far filmmaking and
special effects have come from our
childhood we have three times as many
visual effects slash you know CG visual
effects in general in Jay and Silent Bob
reboot than they did in Star Wars now
that doesn't mean our movies like we're
gonna take you to [ __ ] space it just
means it just means like everything that
counts as an effect shot so anytime we
had people in a car we didn't do a
process trailer we didn't put people in
a car and put the truck car on top of a
truck and then drive the truck around we
just threw him on a green-screen stage
or threw him on a stage put green-screen
beyond him and did the backgrounds later
every one of those shots counts as an
effect shot so I mean even though it
didn't cost as much as blowing up the
Death Star
they're both visual effect shots at the
end of the day so when you just count
them like that we have three times as
many as they had in Star Wars and we're
not even a visual effects heavy movie
like other than the blunt cave sequence
the shots that kind of make up those
shots our replacement taking
green-screen out of [ __ ] driving
shots
taupey [ __ ] like taking we shot at a
courthouse and it said you know
Louisiana parish on the frogs we shot in
Louisiana or Jefferson Parish so you
know we couldn't have it say that for
the movie so they just erased it from
the building you wouldn't know it was
ever there and she had that's an effect
shot that's you know [ __ ] going into
the trench of the Death Star you know
didn't cost and probably cost that's
bout as much maybe more at this bar I
know but that's purely counted as a
affection but not that's again not
bragging I want the Internet to be like
Smith says he's better than Lucas [ __ ]
no although draw your own conclusions
but it's just like that's how far like
that's not even sane and that's just to
say that a movie like ours which is not
special effects heavy or predicated at
all still has a bunch of [ __ ] effect
shots you just can't escape it at this
point because sometimes here's another
example we were using an iPhone pops up
a lot in the [ __ ] movie at one point
in order to use an Apple iPhone which is
their you know property what is it
called intellectual property whatever
for their design their copyright their
trademark their cool they'll let you use
it but it has to match their standard of
what the iPhone is what's on screen has
to look like what's on screen if
somebody had a real iPhone they don't
want you misrepresenting and they are
like fastidious about it so at one point
we had a percentage like first we don't
even know we had to do it we had a green
screen phone and we put the art in later
on and then we sent it through approval
and Apple said oh it's missing the stuff
on top which is the battery the time you
know and a little bar for Wi-Fi or
whatever [ __ ] all standard [ __ ] you
see on top of a legged iPhone screen so
we were like oh oh bummer next time no
no no you got to put that on otherwise
you don't get approval so that became a
visual effect shot like the visual
effects people had to put in those those
little numbers that would have been
there if we hadn't green-screen the
phone because we green-screen it because
we're like I will do it the art later on
and [ __ ] we thought it would save time
and money instead it added an effect
shot to the movie and in order to get
that cleared you know you've got to send
it to them they've got to approve it
they kicked back our first pass because
the wonderful folks at encore and I'd
probably get credit but I should give
him credit you know they were like we
had to put a battery percentage so of
course we chose 69 and
and those ago [ __ ] rocks and they're
like except Apple kicked it back and I
said why me like cuz they don't put the
numbers up anymore now it's just like a
little battery represents life so they
they're like that doesn't exist and if
you're using the iPhone we want you to
represent the iPhone so totally
understandable make sense but we did
have to put that [ __ ] on and that's
considered an effect shot technically so
even though we're not a movie with
effect shots you wind up having a bunch
of backdoor effect shots which sounds
way sexier than I meant it in any event
so that's what I've been doing all week
working on the thing that me and Mark
are working on as well as closing up Jay
and Silent Bob reboot but last we left
we talked about last week yeah
July 2nd which is coming up a week from
now yeah is that right ish yes
spider-man far from home is open and we
talked about hey men like we should do a
screening and then come do the show
because we have a show that day we
should all meet somebody and we should
come up with thankfully somebody far
smarter than me allowed us to do that
thank you
yeah breathtaking our wonderful friend
Brett deacon he's always giving us the
40 X tickets you know that we give out
during the the Q&A at the end
he hooked us up man JC's got details JC
hit the hotspot JC ladies and gentlemen
Berg is the man who owns scum and
villainy give it up for him
[Applause]
tell us the dirty deets we this was a
whimsy that I had at the end of the
thing and I was like I'll pay for it and
I'm not even paying for it somebody else
is paying for it this is how the [ __ ]
rich get richer anyway
tell him the details well it's also
crazy because we put the show up on
YouTube before I had a chance to reach
out to anybody and Bret texted me and
he's like hey so where are you doing the
screening it's like well funny you
should ask I'm in the middle of doing
the 280 third effect shot on Jay and
Silent Bob is that how many it was I
think would you tell me the Star Wars
figures yeah yeah is that wrong
no no it's right it's about I think
there was 70 some-odd and Star Wars and
where it I just found one at the end
that we have to do so I think that's 280
what is the I can't I mean spoilers JC
is what is your official title on
Sisseton editor yes JC is the system and
that job for Pope folks that are like
what does that mean is a very
all-encompassing job I is the editor
literally the only thing I do is cut
picture and sound under and come up with
all that shed build layers and whatnot
if it requires anything more complex
than that I turn over to JC and whatnot
so if it requires a second visual layer
other than like black bars say a special
effect comes in or something like that
if I wanted to make a special effect if
I wanted to take a larger image just
shrink it to a smaller image as I've
been working on the avid editing system
since 96 I still can't do those simple
[ __ ] tasks because there's always
somebody who's like oh I could do that
and JC's been doing it for the last few
flicks so he's also in charge of getting
the effect shots from encore and putting
him into the movie and whatnot so he's
got tons of [ __ ] familiarity with that
that's what he does and one of his many
jobs and the many hats that he [ __ ]
spins but we got way off kilter so I'm
going to working on that and then Brett
text because the show went up I think
Thursday morning and within you know it
was at the end of the show so within two
hours of the show being up he's like hey
we might be able to do something and
then we worked with the screen X people
over the weekend on a Monday they were
like cool we got it so we're doing it on
Tuesday afternoon so that's one week
from today one week from today you'll
have to play hooky from work or taken
early for the July brain doctor's
appointment yeah doctor's appointment
those are magic guys but as
possibly if if you buy tickets to the
show I think there's 20 regular tickets
as of when the show started tonight and
I think I'm gonna try to add like 10 or
15 standing room you get a free ticket
to see spider-man far from home on
opening day at screen X which is the
screen that has the screens on the side
also we're not only gonna see spider-man
far from home we're gonna see the like
here's what you missed if you didn't
have more money and plug in it on the
side they add more pictures to show its
yeah I think it's like a black panther
when you were like flying into one
adorable they added the like extra CG
Wakanda on the sides screen so you
actually feel like you're completely
just like styling it it's like brand-new
digital information that's coming
straight from Marvel and in this case
Marvel and Sony so it's not like oh no
they're just copy-paste it it's all new
[ __ ] they're doing just for this so it
should be pretty cool buy a ticket I
will email you when and where and
address and details and if you want I'm
gonna be here and I'm taking the metro
there so if you're like I want to go but
I don't want to pay for parking twice
park here meet me in the late morning
here and we'll all take the metro as a
fat man be on group down to the theater
watch the movie and then we'll return in
this [ __ ] into a class trip yeah that's
adorable
everybody get up buddy I think we'll
open the bar like whenever the movie
ends cuz it'll end significantly before
the show I think I'll just open the bar
and we can wait to talk about it
everybody will be good drunk by the time
yeah everybody will vant Nast well
number one we thank our friends at 40 X
and screen X for making this opportunity
available to us that's [ __ ] super
sweet also screen X is buying popcorn
soda are you shittin me so it's two if
you're if spider-man isn't enough you're
like
man popcorn and soda for free no no
that's a [ __ ] good and the movie and
then you get to come to the show we love
the folks of for DX and screen X man so
thank you to them for hooking us an ice
it's just something that wimzie de bout
and somebody made it happen for me and
that's why I'm spoiled so that's cool
that we'll have that to look forward to
next episode we're gonna be talking the
[ __ ] about spider-man just having seen
spider-man which by early reports is
fantastic and a little piece of news
they said that this is the official end
of Marvel Universe's phase four four so
endgame they didn't consider the end of
phase four Kevin Feige says this is
absolutely the last chapter of phase
four that's why it's so tied in with
with endgame and the events of endgame
which I would have said like you know
that's where blank died but after Tom
Holland got in trouble this week for
spoiling that like he was somewhere he
was overseas and he talked about the end
of endgame and he says spoilers man if
you don't know the end of endgame and if
you don't how the [ __ ] did you get to
this place tonight you know he was like
you know Tony Stark died and a bunch of
people on social media in England we're
like [ __ ] you spider-man because they
hadn't seen it yet and that you know and
so maybe that's very first world notion
but I'm like how the [ __ ] have you not
how did this movie become the number one
movie of all time almost or very close
to it about to happen unless everybody
[ __ ] saw it passed unnumbered today
but not the number yeah we'll talk about
it that's one of our stories don't take
away our [ __ ] news stories spoilers
oh my god man buggin he worked so hard
on the news man so much copy-pasting if
it's if the movies gonna make two
billion dollars and there's like 7
billion people on earth it's like 1 out
of every 3 people on earth like
including babies has to have seen
endgame how how like if you're old
enough to watch Tom Holland on the news
you're old enough that you should have
seen any game I feel like this is nerve
shaming others thank you how could you
not see endgame the [ __ ] is wrong with
you like I got a family okay oh and he
was like he spoiled him people got
really shitty about him he had to I
don't know if he apologized but it was
like whoa I thought everybody knew that
would have been the assumption that I
had as well yeah
Tony Stark dies you know this yes yeah I
mean right that you know now you've just
earned it
I feel like how how long after Empire
happened did the culture at large know
that you know spoilers just in case I am
your father like yeah I don't know I
don't remember I remember there was like
shitty people online who hated good
things and purity and awesomeness who
would lose like people waiting in line
coming out of the theater online and I
was like mark do you think the Empire
Strikes Back came out twenty years ago
you mean waiting online yeah
because we did that once how funny there
was a waiting online before there was a
waiting online that's my social media
observation so wait people coming out
would say yeah people coming out just to
[ __ ] with people would say hey by the
way it's dead oh my god people were evil
even the 70s is that what you're saying
maybe that was the 80s actually yeah
okay [ __ ] we're way off track spider-man
so next week fat man on fat man be on
next week
spider-man far from home like it's the
best deal on a day that it is man give
it up for Jay Z made it happen as well
you must have done some things this week
I did III went on a trip where I went to
New York oh why to go see a show because
it turns out you can do that if you want
they'll sell you a plane ticket and you
can just fly and then land they may like
I want to go see a show and let me like
great give us money and then you can do
that too
mark just discovered America ladies and
gentlemen I discovered American and
capitalism it's fabulous which show I
went to go see beetlejuice it's so
[ __ ] fun is it it really is it's so
good
I am knows anybody that we know I am NOT
saying that it's good and fun because I
know the guy who wrote the book oh you
do I do a guy wrote the book fella named
Scott Brown was the first person I ever
hired at Entertainment Weekly he was my
assistant when I was the video editor of
Entertainment Weekly and he was an awful
assistant but like the worst like he
couldn't do expenses he couldn't keep a
calendar he couldn't take notes for
phone calls nothing but he could write
like and we all knew it like alright
we're not gonna fire him because he's
really [ __ ] good at writing so let
him do his here and then we'll promote
him and then everybody happy and we
promoted him it became a senior writer
and did amazing stuff and he W and then
left to go to vulture where he was the
theater critic for New York Magazine and
and then he was the theater critic he's
a theater critic for New York all those
people that were like hey man stop
criticizing if you think he's so easy
wants to do he's like alright
Beetlejuice just you wait and then he
shifted it to shift into TV he went to
work on Manhattan he was a writer on
Manhattan and then he was a TV show
about the bomb about the nuclear
families in Los Alamos and and then the
guys who were doing Manhattan brought
him on to help develop a Stephen King
show called Castle Rock and so Scott
told them like listen you need to sit
down you need to meet my friend mark
because he can write be he's a nerd you
guys don't know horror he knows horror
he you absolutely need to have him in
your room so he was my he was my like
guard into Castle Rock David not if it
wasn't for his vouchsafe for my bona
fides I would not have gotten that job
those are a lot of hipster words that
came from an old time before world but
that is how but sweet but it seems like
you paved the way for him and so he in
turn paved the way for you it's I mean
he has been one of my first readers you
know like when I write something and I'm
looking for feedback I'll send it to
Scott Scott gave me notes and vice versa
um but yep known him for 25 years and
then when he told me a man died like
nine years ago I got hard to write
[ __ ] Beetlejuice the music we can you
believe it and I said no why are they
making a beetle just musical he says IP
man I get it and and nine years later
like he's nominated for a Tony for
writing Beetlejuice the musical Wow and
it's and and it's so wonderful to get to
watch somebody do the thing they were
born to do you know and and for that
person to be a friend I gonna have the
last time I felt that before going to
see Bill juice was when I went to go see
you shoot Jay and Silent Bob reboot like
just to get to watch somebody because
I'd never seen you direct before oh you
know like that's right I mean I was in
the cop out set and there wasn't a ton
of directing at that time but but to get
to watch somebody like do the thing they
were born to do and do it well is super
special and kind of magical thank you
and so to get to see my friends show
like you know absolutely fly
cross-country for 36 hours to come and
see [ __ ] Beetlejuice okay so I did
and it was lovely and wonderful what is
the production look like honey it's very
Tim Burton II I mean there's they do
[ __ ] amazing [ __ ] with stage craft
now that I could not have imagined they
do this and they they do the sent the
giant sand worms they they have the
inside of the of Lydia's house the Wow
and but it changes like limits all like
digital projection [ __ ] so it's it's the
nice house when the [ __ ] the
Maitland's yes are moving in and then
when [ __ ] like Otho redesigns it and
then when Beetlejuice takes over like
it's this same stage but looks like
completely different houses and giant
snakes and it's it's [ __ ] awesome
lots of fourth wall breaking lots of and
I remember that I don't remember that
much about the movie like I it's been a
while since I've seen it so I'm like oh
no there's two Harry Belafonte songs so
I know that
and I know they say Beetlejuice three
times so I know that happens but kind of
everything else was a little bit
invented for me and in talking to Scott
about he said yeah the problem was not
only we have the movie to deal with we
had a cartoon that ran for like five or
six years that cartoon was really good
and for lots of people that whether
history of Jews that's what it means
wow that's funny I never thought of that
as being somebody's entry point but yeah
and it ran for a while and it was a
legit cartoon there is a great job
totally and so him having to wrestle
multiple entry points into the same
thing and make it work and make it sing
and then yeah it's awesome I also
discovered how old I am why in in New
York because I was a I was I was on my
way to the airport flying home was
having dinner with with my brother and
his wife and and I said listen I gotta
go cuz I don't want to like I don't
wanna be late to my plan I don't have to
like Oh Jay my way through the airport
yeah and his wife looked at me like well
no oh you don't
because Oh Jay before he was a murderer
did like commercials for Hertz where he
like ran through airports and like
jumped over [ __ ] because he was the
juice and the juice is loose and
whatever she thought your version of OJ
was like I'm gonna stab a bunch of white
lady so I went okay and like just [ __ ]
gloves everywhere I go I was like oh
there's a reference you totally don't
get because you're not like of age and
and then I also like I was so pleased
like I was staying in a hotel in Times
Square and my folks are out on Long
Island so is gonna like walk down
through Times Square I get on the train
along I rode out to Long Island so I got
my backpack on and I'm trudging through
Times Square which is a nightmare
because it's just tourist mecca like
it's nothing but people stopping and
gawking and do tanning out flyers for
Scientology and bus tours and whatever
and like I'm a New Yorker I was born in
New York lived there for like 30 years
and I was just [ __ ] like like I still
have my New York face on which I thought
I lost like it's moving to LA softened
you like you lose almost everything like
you can't handle snow anymore
you can barely like rain as an athame
like you just can't do [ __ ] but I was
like those [ __ ] trudging right and
I'm like stepping and like
yes and uh and nobody tried to give me a
flyer like they looked at me like I
[ __ ] from here he's he don't
wanna you don't want our shitty bus to
her he doesn't want to buy my rap CD and
he doesn't want a comedy club experience
at two o'clock in the afternoon they get
me on everyone here I'm just to like I
can't like you know I just want to
encourage everybody and [ __ ] like I
can't I move fast though I will say that
like my my wife and kid are always kind
of flabbergasted I travel alone mostly
or travel with Jason to places a lot so
when I do travel with my wife and kid I
just in order to get through a space
public space any public space generally
I'm not there to saunter I saunter in
the car but when I'm getting where I'm
getting I know legit even when I was
very heavy I move like a rocket I move
very [ __ ] fast I've been through
airports with you and like it's been a
little bit of me by customs going
calling on me
I can't make it yep you got this stay
golden Ponyboy and he's just [ __ ] off
I just
otherwise I'm I'll miss the plane I you
know what I'm saying like I just but if
you catch me I stop I thought I'll take
a picture and [ __ ] I'm like the
Leprechaun catch me and I'll give you
some [ __ ] gold but but generally
speaking I move pretty [ __ ] fast and
[ __ ] so I I went when they stopped me
I'm kind of like oh okay [ __ ] and I
give people the FaceTime and so even if
they're trying to sell me on something I
cannot tell you how many rap CDs I
bought and I couldn't even have a way to
play them anymore man like so but I feel
like somebody's doing it I'm like go get
a man go get him I had my New York mean
mug on and I was happy as a clam just I
hadn't lost it I still got it I I don't
know if mine's like yeah I don't know if
I
anymore but I don't know if it I
wouldn't attribute that to California as
much as like I'm just a STONER
so like when people like this is my
standard respond
when when I was a kid or how people say
you know [ __ ]
well I asked me how you doing hey man
how you doing man that was old keV
pre-start keV asked me how I'm doing
should I put some mustard on this one no
do it any way you want
no how you doing so good so good really
as always my response and it catches
[ __ ] off-guard man like you
know I do it so much around my wife
she's like shut up but when I do it like
in public and people are just hitting me
with the standard checking yeah like how
you doing and I'm like so good they
[ __ ] look up like really like what
what do you know that I don't it how but
yeah that was that was the big thing
that I did in the last week and I
watched I watched from Jessica Jones you
watched how many episodes I'm three
episodes in like I watch them on the
plane
and is the final season final sin talked
this is the this is the end of news good
okay this is the end of the Marvel net
flix bless ya no work for you if you
look up at a light does it make you
sneeze No
are you serious that's never been a
thing for you know it in order to make
myself sneeze I just have to look up a
bright light and it makes me sneeze
I mean nor make myself blind I look up
at a brown stay with the sound Donald
Trump do it I really I encourage my kid
to do that when she was young maybe I
was wrong that's how I sneeze just
looking up the dogs do it too when I
throw the dogs on their back and pet him
they're forced to look up and then the
one dogs like every time it's you when
he's good cuz you got stuff sinuses and
you can't like teach a dog to blow its
knows I've tried so and if you go over
with a tissue and you try to do it for
him and [ __ ] they're like what what did
I do
so the sneeze is the best way to clear
to find it so no we guys got [ __ ] bad
sinuses so I layer on her back
I've it's Marty the rescue dog Jen's dog
and I stretch her legs out like a mine
she's you know I'm sure other people do
like you know how the dog's legs go like
this and [ __ ] sure and you could stretch
them out if you say so I stretch her out
so she looks like you know like all
completely dog stretched out and I
[ __ ] go ooh look at that that's a
dancers leg look at that leg baby like
your french girls but when I do it she's
on her back and she can't help but look
up and because she's looking up she oh
he sneezes and because she's always
stuff it's big and then she breeds well
and I've my theories that's why she
likes me she's like he gets it like
Jennifer don't do that for her but I'm
like I think I'm legitimately giving
this dog a service that this dogs like
[ __ ] aye-aye captain you know dude do
you think that that dog might be
allergic to dog dander that's why it
sneezes that would suck it was allergic
to itself yeah that's such an
existential crisis man always looking
baffled and that's why it's like I am
allergic to myself I am a German
expressionist film this is the time we
sneeze yeah Jessica Jones I've seen
three episodes I like the first one
quite a bit okay I like the third one
quite a bit okay
the second one is about Trish Walker
Patsy Patsy and yeah I didn't I didn't
need that one all right
it just it's it's one of those things
where like the the first episode ends
with it with a cliffhanger and it's
pretty strong and then it comes back and
you're like [ __ ] you and your
cliffhanger let's talk about this chick
for a while and like Patsy / Trish was
always my kind of least favorite part of
that show like just what was that an aw
you love the character I thought that
was an all like Oh finally somebody said
it I know you know you're like oh good
mark you're wrong oh you're dead
yeah because they're right thank you
what they do is it what's your character
it's a Hellcat do they reference they do
there's a tiny little Hellcat not in
there which is cute
but it's like the the the propulsion of
the story was such that I didn't want to
drop anchor with a character that I'm
not as invested in as I am in my lead I
feel this soon into the show like
Episode two is like oh we're just gonna
do a flashback episode about Batsy sure
I just want to take you back to a time
when the best comic book movie we had
was like yeah not even man you guys know
what I'm saying
and then they gave us such beauty such
perfection man and and Netflix Marvel is
done and like it'll never happen again
in that beautiful shining jewel that we
all wanted is now just fading away and
this is their last gasp and as they lie
there dying you cut its [ __ ] throat
man you like [ __ ] Patsy I I choose to
think of it as that I'm laying it out on
its back and I'm just pulling its legs
and look at you with your dancers legs
Steve make its knees my face all right
so you watch that so what's your first
to me and already you liked it and three
I liked as well because like it's it's a
private eye store it's a detective story
and once it gets back on its [ __ ] clue
trail then you're like alright I'm in
I'm invested who's the big bed we don't
know yet oh really yeah that's part of
the mystery but no it's it's there's a
lot of it to recommend and it still it
still is I think uniformly the best of
those shows maybe I didn't I didn't love
the second season much I loved the first
the first is Burt was of any Marvel
Netflix show I still loved daredevil
season one as my all-time favorite but I
agree jazz Jessica Jones season one is
awesome right next it's exemplary and I
think that like on average Jessica Jones
has been better than the other shows
have been on average so so I'm I have
faith not take for Dead shows yeah you
were on the mean average of quality is
okay so weird that it's all over
remember when it was starting we're like
oh my god there's 13 [ __ ] hours of
daredevil to watch like yeah it could
have been 10 but [ __ ] I'll watch all 13
and [ __ ] I like pizza
more pizza yeah and now it's just now
it's done man
it's all over yeah life moves pretty
fast you don't stop once in a while and
look around you can miss it profound
welcome alright did you do anything else
nah man no I mean I I apparently man I
worked out two TV shows at once which is
probably not advised yeah so don't tell
my other boss Internet he did and he
also didn't show up for the other day so
I became the other boss and this is what
the [ __ ] is he yeah I was first mark and
what have I got a doctor yes I didn't
want to tell him he said his other job
yeah I've got 19 dead grandfather's
everybody gets one Hey
so last week when we showed a bunch of
[ __ ] that we got premiums and stuff like
that
who's the Ghostbuster fan in the bunch
this is the scary library ghost anybody
anybody is that yeah you I catch well
done
I then throw it as much as propeller
that is a hockey players throw it was
certainly not a baseball players throw
this is a bag of Doritos
it's a spider-man yeah [ __ ] yeah Doritos
tasty so this is the way that it came in
and it's a it's a backpack
it says Doritos on it I'll be honest
there were four pins and I took two of
the pins for myself yeah [ __ ] yeah
you're standing all right back
Wow what a manly throw how about that
[ __ ] was gonna come back like a
boomerang [ __ ] man I was all-american
terms and Dragons was [ __ ] impressive
okay yeah that's all we got for the
upfront now we're red is that right or
that's it that's it so now we know yes
yeah diving into the new gentlemen mr.
mark barnard was a former news hound he
gave up the news biz to be a writer and
[ __ ] like that but news is in his blood
he can't get rid of it so every once in
a while he just has to search [ __ ]
news out from people who already
published it and then brings it here to
the bar and gives us the news so mark
printed up the news give it up for Mark
Bernard someday someday I want the
version of that intro that's like the
Knight Rider intro no mark barnard he
used to make the news yes shadowy flight
into the world this did not exist
Michael Knight a lone Crusader for truth
and justice it sounds like you've
already written it I'm just telling you
man I just want the [ __ ] like mean a
TransAm I'm the [ __ ] salt flats with
the Sun rising behind me and Mike Post
theme music underneath you my intro is
not good enough no I want that plus all
of it I know it seems like a lot reading
fair enough boy we've created a monster
[ __ ] I know uh so the first one is a
slightly sad one vertigo comics Oh at
least it wasn't a human being but yes
but this is sad farewell to vertigo
vertigo
DC's line it's a dolt line which was
always misleading because I remember
when they announced a dolt line I was
collecting back then I was like a dolt
line and looked for sex none it just
meant these were comics that were for
people that weren't used to comics that
were for grown-ups
right as the marketplace was shifting in
the 80s I believe this was when they
started early 1993
all right so late so early 93 my dad
marketplace was [ __ ]
we'd all seen grown-up comics at this
point Frank Miller had done Dark Knight
Returns The Watchmen
The Watchmen had happened and stuff but
there was no way to say hey this is
where the comic books for adults go
which is what the marketplace had become
mostly adults and stuff so they created
this imprint called vertigo and that's
like before vertigo Swamp Thing as
written by Alan Moore was just in the DC
Universe which would have been
confounding like to a vertigo fantasy
man and stuff like that but they didn't
have vertigo when they did that book and
stuff so they created a line for books
like that Neil Gaiman's Sandman of
course being one of the biggest and best
and most well remembered what else did
they do at vertigo that I love creature
why the last man at last man preacher
preacher fables Hellblazer yeah a long
time was published over there scalped
that's right some on Jeff Lewis and his
stuff came out of here to go he said
he'll blazer the losers the kitchen
which has actually been turned into a
feature it's coming out for more others
right with Melissa McCarthy transmitted
chapala hundred bullets [ __ ] as a Rolo
absolutely right yeah trying to dreams
Metropolitan Grant's Metropolitan where
they gave home to people like Warren
Ellis yeah I mean that was first
published under helix was another
imprint that when I hold my god that
went away a long time got absorbed by it
yeah like it was and it became in a real
way the first imprint that had an
identity yes in a way like there was
always Marvel you Marvel QD rad easy kid
but vertigo became like the HBO of
comics right oh well done excellent
[ __ ] Paul man that's a good good so
like the meeting now have a vertical
book you were guaranteed a certain
amount of quality yeah
often it wasn't in the art because
especially that first early wave of
vertigo it seemed as if the art was so
bad to focus on the words because they
wanted to be literary Wow [ __ ] way to
go after him as they died and [ __ ]
I'm just saying in the beginning they
were hard to look at but we grew to love
them anyway
but I mean it's they they did amazing
stuff amazing work they gave birth to an
amazing crop of creators and they were
inside of DC that create her own place
for you to go like if you had an idea
that was not gonna be owned by DC it was
it was like it was also came out just
kind of around the image era as well and
image was doom crane around
and so this was DC's idea of how to keep
creators and invite creators and give
them ownership like this is your book
Brian cave on like we will take you know
a little bit off the top to print it out
but like all this money is yours and and
no other major company had done that
before Karen Berger Karen Berger was the
flagship editor Karen Berger kicked it
off and was in charge for a long long
time she was until 2009 2010 I think
yeah she was kind of the heart and soul
of the operation it was her idea her
imprint and she ran it the way she saw
fit and you know she probably more than
just Marvel and DC I mean I understand
that DC was part of I mean vertigo is
part of DC but the vertigo line probably
more so than those two major imprints
were what brought me back into comic
books where I was like oh my god this is
where it is now yeah and she was a
tastemaker think about it like all my
favorite writers came out of England and
worked at vertigo and she hand-picked so
many as she would go over like once a
year and just go sit down with Grant
Morrison and Neil Gaiman and Garth Ennis
and [ __ ] write like he's somebody's
cat's you don't get I mean because did
vertigo did vertigo do the Arkham Asylum
hardcover or was that DC is the um I
think that was DC maybe she edited she
might have because you know Grant was
the kind of writer at that time who if
you liked an editor and they had a good
relationship then that editor would do
whatever he did so would not surprise me
at all if he did Arkham Asylum - yeah
man it was a it was a really amazing
imprint and now DC is just kind of
letting it go they're letting it go
they're realigning their publishing line
to to make it a little bit more like
divided by age like they've got a DC
kids line which is just for like why and
young stuff DC proper which is all their
superhero titles and then DC Black Label
which will be what says sexy man's like
something we're get high this comic
comes with a joint black label but that
is going to function much in the way
that vertigo did which is this is our
adult stuff this is our not for kids
line I read one of the rationales which
kind of made sense to me with her leg
look when we started vertigo vertigo
meant something because they're like
that's that could only be a vertigo book
but he's like to be fair the comics
industry has risen to that point where
everybody kind of works on that level
now I'm not saying they're as good as
all the vertigo books but they're all
they're not kidding themselves they're
all pretty much making comic books for
adults at this point right so at you
know they're like you don't really need
that differentiation what you do need is
differentiation to be like these comics
are for your kids these comics for your
teenagers these comics are for you and
let's be honest your teenagers as well
makes sense I guess but sad to see
something go away but boy it was
beautiful and did so much serve its
purpose and [ __ ] and all good things
come to an end except God willing those
Marvel movies I don't know if I want to
live in a world without that [ __ ] but
yeah and it also would not surprise me
if in like 15-20 years they decide to
bring it back
you're absolutely there's nothing good
ever stays wait a second in this
realignment what happens to Gerard ways
young animals it gets folded under the
black label line as does the Sandman
stuff like all everything that they had
been publishing they're still publishing
they're just shifting it and putting a
different tag on it fair enough but
weird watching a big part of our past
and history die yeah give it up for
vertigo man they [ __ ] set a standard
[Applause]
all right that's that's it you know
what's making me happy though what Flash
Gordon what's going on Oh
news to me you actually caught my
breaking news you are Sony wants to make
an animated Flash Gordon film and
they've retained the services of one
Taika Waititi to write and direct you
have my attention
wow yeah yeah so Sony the same people
who gave us spider-man gasps are into
the spider-verse
are talking about doing animation Flash
Gordon yes all right so that also has my
attention they caught my attention
big-time at the last flick but him him
take all my money right now
I love for Flash Gordon is ridiculous
and unbounded my he's the right guy cuz
thor ragnarok played like a quasi sequel
to flash board so it's clearly
influenced it yeah it's probably gonna
be me I think but it's unclear I mean
make there's a Ming problem clearly
because Ming came out of like the Yellow
Peril over their 30s and 40s that right
yeah like Ming recently from another
planet he's from [ __ ] yeah but he was
always like an Asian guy I mean you just
like funny wasn't it was a Max von Sydow
played him yeah which is a whole nother
thing I mean that's that's the thing
that you can't do anymore but it's like
foo Manchu and Charlie Chan and Ming the
Merciless all come out of manchu was
from Earth yeah Charlie Chan was from
Earth this is a guy who'd like comes
from another planet yeah he's really a
mustache and [ __ ] bald head I don't
honestly I don't think of him as Asian
cuz I think of him as Max von Sydow you
could just make him blue or some [ __ ] if
they mean I'm blue that's a whole
different thing instead they made him
yellow wait in this GaN the comic strips
in the comics they did yes he was Asian
in the comics
I was saying if we make them blue now
than a dome a you're good yeah yeah just
make him an ally and he's from [ __ ]
yeah long as he's [ __ ] bald and he's
got pointing eyebrows don't really
[ __ ] matter and and mean eyebrows
like [ __ ] gliders on board like you
just let us as long as he's a person of
color regardless of color that's fine
that's the rules
green green yeah thank you my friend
Tiger YTD you know I and my role as duly
appointed ambassador of people of color
hereby granted you we get the a-ok from
POC you totally do
thank you Roger Roger so that's
happening there's no date on it yet it's
still very to me honestly like legit
exciting I would look forward to that
man
true talent work of the true talents
like that spider-man movie looked
amazing that's what Sony animation is up
to [ __ ] go ahead take spar take Flash
Gordon and smart to not just like hey
let's do this
live-action especially so close to
Ragnarok which is like well they just
kind of did that yeah so I don't know
this is this might be a smart approach
to a live-action eventually Flash Gordon
you could certainly take the medium and
stretch it and do fun things like I look
forward to this that's hard I had no
idea that exists I will just be upset if
they don't use the Queen music if they
don't use both welcome flash ah he's
saved every one of us Wow we're gonna go
on tour you guys
remember how we talked it must have been
like six months ago that uh that
millennium films was making a Red Sonja
movie just say jokes all the ways doing
red songs yeah I was get it that's
[ __ ] amazing give it up for Jill
Soloway she's doing Red Sonja Jill
Soloway he's doing red soon I heard
that's amazing when I saw this [ __ ]
story announced I was like oh my god
millennium wins because remember at
first they were going like now we're
gonna stick with the original guy and
then finally the whole world was like
bro and they were like alright yeah we
don't know what we were thinking you
know then the question of course was
like well they probably should go to
somebody like billet how about it's Red
Sonja yeah maybe you should go for a
woman and they chose well now Jill
Soloway is that she's non-binary is that
correct I believe my bad so I kept
saying so Jill Soloway is a big
beautiful human being and kid it's just
the absolute [ __ ] like brilliant
choice yes not the first not the most
obvious some would argue not [ __ ]
commercial but you don't need to be the
commercial choice when you've got the
commercial IP and the property and a
good idea paired with a good idea it
could be a great idea yeah I mean that's
that's equivalent like Sam Mendes doing
a Bond movie right which is actually
[ __ ] smarter but yes you're
absolutely right but a Sam and is known
for America known for like prestige and
award-winning stuff like coming in and
doing the genre thing to elevate the
genre right because of experience and
taste and class and all that so yes her
coming in Emmy award-winning director
writer producer Jill Soloway doing Red
Sonja is kind of a masterstroke when I
read that I was like oh my god like
that's so [ __ ] smart like they just
saved that project because it was pretty
[ __ ] tainted but right now it's like
I saw a bunch of news sites generally
would [ __ ] on news like that go I'm into
this yeah you know what I'm saying like
people reconsider and and honestly like
you know I'm I don't know that to me is
interesting like I'll [ __ ] see that
take like I'll pay to see that take way
more interesting than the other one to
say the least but even more interesting
than just like hey we're doing it again
we're doing Red Sonja again giving it to
like somebody that like they're not
always like here here's the ten people
we always give this [ __ ] to like just
the same way Tyco tyka got to step up
and go from like you know in the what we
do in the shadows or were the what was
it yeah well they're people under the
willow people will be to ragnarok like
just pick somebody that is not the
obvious [ __ ] choice and let's see
what [ __ ] it happens like and that ain't
a [ __ ] commercial for me I don't want
to do that [ __ ] at all I like these
choices that they're making is all I'm
getting at they're not the [ __ ] same
people it's not the obvious [ __ ]
choice and I think it's gonna result in
[ __ ] an interesting movie so far it's
been working man so I think this is a
really cool idea yeah we got there we
did that is big news man I remember
reading that and being like oh my god
that's so smart alright what else you
got
Marvel is thirsty there they are thirsty
for the highest-grossing movie of all
time
oh yes they're so [ __ ] close and they
by the way deserve it right they they
they beat Avengers end game did beat
avatar in its initial theatrical run
avatar was released a bunch of different
times in the theater and so and so now
was it released it was yeah you like
added another yeah like everybody gets
like when it movies like that against
its fancy Ashley release and so and so
Marvel is now bringing Avengers end game
kind of quote-unquote back into theaters
it's never really left but it's there
they're adding a deleted scene with like
temp effects oh really
yeah like they're not fully realizing it
so here's the see we cut that we didn't
want us and they're not putting it into
the movie proper they're adding it to
the end they're adding an intro with Joe
Russo and they're adding a sort of
featurette I think leading into
spider-man far from home so I can sort
of a mentally memorial
how does the only memorial thing look oh
that's great that they're even throwing
us a bone to incentivize it for me all
they had to say was like we're so
[ __ ] close go one more time because I
was down for the cause you know little
victories in life that's all I look for
and somebody's like we have a chance to
[ __ ] it over take avatar I'm like that's
the kind of mindless [ __ ] that I
need to get behind and yeah all for it I
would have done it without them they're
somewhere in like thirty five million
dollars shy and so is this enough to get
them over the hump I don't know but
they're they're hoping they're making
one last [ __ ] valiant effort I'm
gonna go I'll go yeah I got three hours
to kill but I would like to see him do
it and not because I'm like [ __ ] avatar
I just reward that reward that series
man like it gave me so much joy and they
seemed to want that that dopey crown
give it to them they're so [ __ ] close
like I'm all for it I'm all for this
last if they're thirsty let's give them
something to drink
40 million 40 million more how many more
to get it somewhere around thirty five
million sounds doable and sure yeah if I
was that man I would just leave it in
theaters for ten years man even even if
they were like we did $300 this week
really we're almost there
we're gonna beat those [ __ ] blue cats
all right so that's happening that's one
as of this Friday reason to go to the
movie theater and that's right before
Spiderman opens a few days later yeah oh
my god they're gonna be competing
against themselves to a certain degree
well not really cuz one's Disney and
one's Sony yes
yes yeah yeah and the only other
competition hasn't yesterday which is
opening on Friday the Beatles movie
Danny Boyle's be deserving yes one other
piece of news is kinda less news and
more rumor I think but let's talk about
it okay I'm not a journalist anymore I
only play one on TV the rumor is that
Michael B Jordans
matrix film wait what
yes no you say that like we're all
supposed to know talked about it before
is there a matrix film with Michael B
Jordan an exact pen who wrote ready
player one but most other things the
first he's credit on the adventures as
well like six or seven months ago
tweeted that he was yes indeed working
with Warner Brothers on a new Matrix
movie the rumor was that Warner Brothers
desperately wanted Michael B Jordan to
be the star of this Matrix movie the
knio knio knio knio proto neo thank you
I felt kind of proud of that went over
like a lead balloon a Mike [ __ ] my shits
off the rumor is is that that which are
skis are coming back to do this fourth
oh right on
really yes good that is unconfirmed by
everyone so like take it with like a
Salt Lick and not just a grain of salt
but it would be I want to see them make
good on what the last couple of Matrix
movies were like I feel like if they
come back now they can save every one of
us from the last two Matrix movies we'd
have to go back in time you're saying in
some not that they need to by any
stretch of the imagination but this
fourth Matrix movie could make up for
two and three it's just like if you're
going to go out go out strong smart
because I it's it's hard to recall being
quite as disappointed as I was after the
first 20 minutes of like Matrix Reloaded
where like I was so [ __ ] excited for
those movies like they're kind of ready
back and there's the directors and we're
doing it and the trailers are [ __ ]
awesome and then you sit there and you
like but okay uh-oh sure wha go chase
cool Oh
I mean yeah as the that's a choice
director of Jay and Silent Bob reboot I
have no comment whatsoever it's all me
yes that's a wait so that's the rumor is
that is the mushaf skis might come back
correct I'd be [ __ ] genius it'd be I
mean I understand like it's a Warner
Brothers property at this point and
belongs to them they can do whatever
they want with it but the Wachowski is
so tied to like I can't think of
creation creator separation that makes
less sense that was so uniquely them
yeah and to then just have somebody be
like like you know we love Batman we
talk about Batman I've worked in comics
I'm Batman they make a thousand versions
of Batman all the time it's a character
that could have a bunch of permutations
or interpretations and nobody ever goes
ha we're [ __ ] on the memory of Bob
Kane because most people are like well
he's not really the guy or whatever the
[ __ ] so but the matrix is so [ __ ]
with shouse keys yeah and I know they've
done Animatrix and but didn't they also
write oversaw I mean they they were the
executives and they they oversaw
everything this was their baby and and
it you know I don't give a [ __ ] like we
do razz on the 2 and the 3 of it all but
like matrix is hands-down one of the 50
most brilliant pieces of pop-culture
centum ever made in that and I feel
shitty throwing in pop-culture cinema so
I'll just [ __ ] take out pop culture
and just say one of the 50 best most
original most inventive [ __ ] movies
like ever [ __ ] made and so to have
those cats be like oh we're gonna have
somebody else do it didn't feel [ __ ]
right feels way more right to have a
house keys come back yeah like having
them come back and do another matrix is
like having George Miller come back for
fury road yes it's like oh I didn't I
almost didn't know that I wanted it but
now that I'm hearing about it it makes
all the sense in the world to the point
where you can't imagine anybody else
doing that and did anybody else ever
handle Mad Max
no no right it was all that's true it's
always George Miller so that's like very
uniquely identified with them as well
yeah man that's uh that's that's that's
cool news yeah on two fronts I mean we
talked about the Michael B Jordan thing
we did yeah Jesus I smoked away half the
show and then and then I get to enjoy it
later on when you I'm like what the [ __ ]
and you're like we just talked about
this all right what are the news we go
that's it man that's it that's it slim
news week I hate these weeks or at
months where we go back to back to back
Tom the show's because not a lot happens
from Tuesday - Tuesday I get says a lot
of news we did all right I getting
spoiled I guess what is there video game
news man where's Nate you know something
about Harry Potter a are his Nagin's
olives everybody give it up for nephews
correspondent now I guess Nate's the guy
who does the artwork for our show that
you've seen online and that we sell here
at the cantina
he's our artist but he's the artist in
residence but he's also smartest in
residence well done he's also a rhyming
I mean it a cat who knows a thing or two
about games so we were talking about
backstage there's a new Harry Potter
game that got an ass cuz we were like
what news are we gonna talk about that's
how the show comes together we're in the
alley where am I like what the [ __ ] are
we gonna do and so we brought up the
video game but you didn't know enough
other than there is a game right I
didn't know enough other than there's a
game I knew it was like Pokemon go which
I also didn't play but that was about it
Nate seem to know something about it so
he said we're gonna give the mic to Nate
everyone give it up for Nate
tell us about this proposed videogame
well they've just released a Harry
Potter skinned Pokemon go game which is
essentially since Pokemon go came out
what 20 years ago they've basically just
like a bunch of different companies I
don't know I know the Harry Potter one
it's the same company but like a couple
of different franchises have tried to do
that game right Ghostbusters did it how
was the Ghostbusters one it's fine
what ringing endorsement man that's a
poster quote right there I love those
clusters it's my favorite movie um but
they're mobile games you know they're
just you've got to pay to play pay to
win and it's all microtransactions so
it's the base game itself or at least
I'm going by the Ghostbusters one
because I didn't play and I played a
little bit of Pokemon but the
Ghostbusters one especially is just like
yeah if you want to progress is that
that you guys are all have it what the
Ghostbusters Wizards unite that's the
harry potter one oh it's available
already just came out yeah it's fine
jump up onto the wall grab a mic in yeah
come on Chloe always played it man
Chloe's here everybody give it up for
chloe dykstra nothing that you did a
fine job sorry Nate sorry to steal away
from you yeah it's fine like I played it
for a day I was like oh it's basically
Pokemon go but slightly less no you
choose less of an incentive to to do
things in it
are you trying to find like other
players and is that part of the game or
is I go you're awful yeah oh my god wait
to them I can swear you in the house go
Darien can shame the home oh [ __ ] my
boyfriend's a Hufflepuff right say
they're cuddly and that's awesome do you
get to pick your houses
yeah yeah or do they sort you into it no
you need to pick it i I went through
Potter porn pop Pottermore safe water
porn Potter Potter porn
so tonight otherwise who chooses the
wand that is very and then they pull out
the watch and they turn back time and
nothing ever happened
what's a Quaffle you don't want to know
yeah basically you have to walk I hate
it oh it's one of those games where you
have to walk around find ins and then
you find what are they called what are
the things called there no not the
fortresses they're called the confound
the confundus yeah and then you have to
banish them you're for Warner Brothers
so you know maybe you should be up here
I'm like Harry Potter Pokemon go here we
go it's items within the manage magical
universe that you have to either free or
collect to turn back into the Ministry
of Magic all right so it's like the map
and [ __ ] you just have to send them back
to the Wizarding World but it's fun fun
no I would say it's not it's free yeah
yeah you you absolutely can it's kind of
like Pokemon go you can enjoy it without
paying but you have to have friends and
you have to like walking and you know
walking I'm out man walking him friends
no walking that's for [ __ ] muggles
good one all right man give it up for
Chloe she played the game thank you
before we dive into normally we dive
into QA but we got [ __ ] we got a yes
yeah gasps man mark hooked us up you
would imagine like me I work in the
business I know people and [ __ ] like
that i but director I've casted people I
should be coming up with guests galore
but every guest so far I think we've
ever had marks brought in I'm so
appreciative yes but I was at comic-con
I want to say
a couple years back and and at some
party at some place I can't remember
there was the alcohol and uh and and our
guest came up he's like man I love the
[ __ ] podcast like thank you so much
you're far too handsome to be liking our
podcast this is getting weird
yeah and he's like well no it's because
I you know I'm on the show it's it's
sci-fi called Krypton you didn't say it
Krypton I just like to say Krypton
Krypton but it's so it's very Marlon
Brando Marlon Brando the Krypton and
then I remember DC had like a watch a
long premiere party for it and he flew
in from the UK and I was invited to this
day and we just kind of hung out for a
bit I'm like man if you ever back in LA
you should come on the podcast I would
[ __ ] love to and then he's like I'm
gonna do the accent I just I just moved
to Los Angeles and I'm around I was like
you want to come to the podcast I love
to so you were to be on the Packers I
would [ __ ] love to so so it's exactly
how I said it as well and so so yes
welcome to the to the hot spot Cameron
cuff the star of sci-fi in DC's Krypton
Cameron everyone thanks for having Oh
cheers guys thank you so much Thank You
Cameron it is I mean do you try to
[ __ ] look like Superman yeah and I'm
gonna complete the person no one can
recognize me anymore it's like anyone I
pulled up I was like oh my god he's here
yeah what yeah episode 3 is on this
Wednesday can still catch up on on Syfy
online or on demand and this is the
season with Lobo Lobo absolutely Lobos
gonna get a show bow indeed it's it's
really excited like one of the cool
things about our show is were sort of
committed to doing the cosmic aspect of
the DC Universe and we debuted
characters like Adam Strange and Lobo
and there are many many more we want to
do that's for that you've got my vote
instantly like I remember when they
first talked about this oh no who's here
in Hollywood
we were like a [ __ ] show about
Superman's grandpa family yeah and pug
and literally it is flying and they're
going into their second season and by
all reports like legit wonderful and I
know people that worked on and stuff
like that they're they're bringing cool
new ideas yeah they're really making it
[ __ ] work in a way that like at first
you were like no this couldn't possibly
what was the process like to be picked
as Superman's grandpa yeah it was kind
of I I before I was ever involved in it
I was just a fan I'm a huge DC fanboy
and and I saw get announced and I was
like Superman grandfather really why and
well the thing is I was I was in those
comments
I was watching people share my show
before I was in it like it was it was
sort of crazy to watch but then all of a
sudden it happened and and the audition
happened I was still doing mic theater
and indie movies and stuff like that in
London and then Krypton came around and
this is a massive America this is
Superman like they're not gonna why why
would they be interested in me and I
went in and I did a tape and I got
turned down for it twice but it just
never it never went away and then
eventually I was working on my first
American TV show and in Brooklyn and
what was the first it was a show that
lasts about six episodes and then what
was it called it was called time after
time based on the movie time based on
the movie time at the time yeah yeah I'm
who was in it Josh Bowman and Freddie
stroma were and it was ABC show it was
it was a really fun show it's really
love to do and you know like a lot of
shows nowadays just didn't find the
audience but I [ __ ] love that movie
alright so I was working on that and
then all of a sudden I get a phone call
from my agent says you know you got to
do another tape of krypton and at this
point I'm like look I'm working for the
14-hour days here and I miss is my first
big American thing and I want to make
sure I do a good job so let's just ask
you know is there anything I can do
differently because I've been turned
down multiple times at this point and
then I got a phone call that night
saying bring your suitcases to set
because you're flying to LA tomorrow and
there I was in a room in LA 24 hours
later testing for David Goyer who's a
hero of mine you know it you know made
two of the greatest comic book films of
all time you know he's
an incredible incredible guy and there I
was and I kind of still didn't think I'd
get it so I saw the sides and I thought
they could be played really honestly and
sort of straightforward and very sort of
stoic but then I saw that there was
actually a lot of humor in them and that
this was something different it was
something cool and I decided to go a
little bit more with the sort of the
roguish aspect of it and bring a bit
more humor into it and I I think I was
the first person to make him laugh and I
think that was that was the thing and I
ended up getting the role and then I was
in Serbia three days later filming the
pilot which was is that where they shot
the pilot yeah we shot the pilot in
Serbia yeah it was it was and then we
filmed we thought one hour so it's like
your cast you're like [ __ ] a where we
go and the Serbian [ __ ] that's the
Phantom Zone of shooting it was
belgrade's great it's a really amazing
city and it was really really cool cuz
we this amazing back lot and the thing
is the thing that most people don't
realize about the show is that it's all
practical except for the cityscapes all
of those sets are real you know yeah
it's really like being that we had a bob
not unlike this bar it's the first time
you see me in the show and all the back
lots are there they're all real it's
really genuinely being in that world so
in Serbia we genuinely had this massive
cityscape of candle credits a lot
further there than it would here so that
was the pilot where do you guys shoot
the Belfast Ireland yeah it's good fun
this is a show that requires a [ __ ]
passport to work on man like they send
you all over the world we're all Brits
are Irish so it kinda makes sense yes
everyone's like why you kryptonians
English it's like well it's cheaper so
take us back a bit because I know that
you're a nerd yes sir a self-described
nerd where did you learn to begin I was
I grew up with the great animated series
I grew up with Andrea Romano and bruised
him and like Kevin Conroy was my Batman
I open up
he is like those like Andrea Romano I
think is one of the greatest directors
of all time to find those actors who are
just those roles I pick up a comic book
now I open it and I read it and those
are the voices I hear and I think we all
kind of grew up with a sort of cursory
knowledge of who these characters are if
you think about it like the JLU cartoon
was in many ways one of the first shared
universes so I grew up with it with a
lot more knowledge than people in Prior
generations might not might not have and
then I picked up
you remember those big encyclopedias on
Batman yeah I opened up one of them and
I that was the first time I learned
about Jason Todd and now is the first
time I learn about Tim Drake and Dick
Grayson why and how old people are
distinct Robins and all of their
relationships are so deep and it goes
much further than that and then I picked
up Geoff Johns Teen Titan run and that
was the thing just blew it all open for
me because you realize that this is a
universe it has deep deep mythology that
is all based on personal stakes and
personal relationships and that was what
brought me into comic books that's why I
love it now it's all about people
connecting to each other and I really
just love that DC kid clearly always you
never went on the other side of the
street I did I always loved the x-men
but I I think for me the reason I love
DC and maybe it's because I came to it
first but as a universe had always felt
more connected to me it always felt like
everything sort of emanates from the
Justice League outward and again it's
that thing of the personal relationships
you can really clearly trace the
relationship between the outsiders and
the Justice League and the injustice
league in the Justice League it all
seems to be based on that whereas I
loved characters within Marvel but the
Hulk wasn't so connected to the x-men
you know yeah but I'd marvel suffer and
I'm sure somebody online will kick me in
the nuts for saying if it felt more
episodic more as the DC stuff to me
always felt more soap operatic yeah like
it felt like an ongoing dishy universe
of like oh did you see what [ __ ] Tim
Drake did and yet like more so then the
Marvel stuff was very episodic and they
could crossover characters and stuff but
here's your adventure here's your
adventure and they just kept their
universe kind of going and constantly
referred to [ __ ] that happened
like yeah so I could you know that's
that's how I really it felt like the the
the stakes of the universe were more
sort of present in the stories and I'm
sure that there are plenty of Marvel
fans who would disagree but for me that
was it was always just DCA so and what
part of UK did you grow up in London
right like right in London yeah yeah
Hammersmith what is oh my god I can wear
the Apollo is exactly I played at the
Apollo what is it like to grow up and I
didn't to be [ __ ] it was the London
Hammersmith Apollo not the Apollo what
is it like growing up in like some
people of course grew up in this city
but what's it like growing up in like
that to us is [ __ ] exotic like London
I mean it's cool when the thing is like
London I think now means something
different than it did then like I said
to you before growing up in London the
90s was kind of like growing up in
America in the 80s like we were just a
little bit behind like in terms of like
fashion style and all that sort of stuff
but the thing that my dad's from Boston
he's from America and my mother's from
London and for me that meant I grew up
with stories I grew up with American
movies and then British theatre and I
remember the first time I meant I
winters and sorry Chloe I'm about to
reference your father's work that the
first time I ever went to the cinema was
the 1990s re-release of a new hope you
know and that to me was how we spend
time together as a family was watching
the movies so London I think was perfect
for me because it was such a gateway to
all of that he had movies he had amazing
art he had amazing culture and it's a
gateway to Europe as well so you could
travel but for me my childhood was films
and I think very naturally from there a
segue to comic books and a big comic
book culture there as well oh you guys
were saying before so many of the great
comic book talents and you know Mark
Miller Graham Morrison Gary Frank Alan
Moore you know there's a real real
history of comic books in England for
sure
was it what what's it like being a
British actor who wants to do genre
stuff in a in an environment where your
local productions weren't making a lot
of genre stuff like like coming out of
you know University and wanting to get
into it like
path did you decide to set for yourself
to hopefully get here yeah I truthfully
I never thought I would you know I think
you know I I grew up in London I trained
to be an actor in Ireland and I think
the expectation is that you go into
theatre and that's where I was for a
while that's where I was before crypt I
was doing you know costume dramas and
you know putting on a weird costume and
mustache and anyone for tea and all sort
of that you know it's you know it's it
isn't it isn't Star Wars it's not it's
not comic books but the thing is I was
just sort of content to be a fan that's
what it was to me I thought you know I'm
always going to enjoy this thing but
it's so far away and it felt so far away
but you know with the advent of things
like self taping and stuff like that
that industry is so global now it's not
far away and and also behalf of the
stuff shoots in Pinewood anyway it's
it's um it's not as far away as it once
was but I think yeah in in London you
don't really expect that this all I I
feel like I won the lottery that's the
truth of it all I feel like I got
tremendously lucky and I'll never feel
anything different really now you get
your three episodes in the season 2 as
season 1 marinated enough like it's on
sci-fi but yes you can watch it but has
it gone to wherever it's next life as
does it go to a Netflix yeah you guys
can all watch it on on the DC Universe
streaming it season one's all there the
season 2 premieres there as well so now
at this point what is the do people go
like holy [ __ ] you're Superman's grandpa
like I I I always I always say I'm at
the now I walk around in glasses and no
one recognizes me no I I'm at the
perfect level of Fame which means that
people only give a [ __ ] who I am in San
Diego within three blocks on one weekend
of the earth it's it's that's a great
currency right it's great one weekend in
the year I'm super famous within a
three-block radius and then I can go
home and no one cares it's wonderful
have you did they do a panel pre Oh
Debbi done San Diego yeah I did my first
well it's funny you actually you didn't
remember how he met that was one of the
best nights of my life
because
genuinely the thing is Tom Taylor the
writer of injustice one of my favorite
comic books literally took me under his
wing and said hey man I know you're a
huge fan we were just friends from
Twitter and he took me around he
interests me to Gimli and Steve all and
Nicholas Scott like right it was it was
one of the most because the thing is I
genuinely am just a nerd living the
dream and when I go to Comic Con for me
that's about meeting the comic-book
people like that those are the people
who told my stories you still tell my
stories and they're the most people for
me Comic Cons are deeply special place
and and always will be so so you're done
production yes sir on the second season
do you guys have any inkling about
season three if you heard a thing well
you know that announces development
happening on a Lobo show a showboat
sober and and hopefully season three
follows swiftly on from that but there
are so many stories want to tell as I
said this is a story of the DC cosmic
universe there are so many characters
like the Omega Man like Santa gar and
ran and places that we want to go when
they referent they made out of a
stranger character I was like [ __ ] man
that's deep yeah it's like that's so
smart he's such a great character and
they figured out a way to use him like
creatively to make that Superman story
work I can't grab me where I was like
you know first they were like Superman's
grandpa I'm like and then they were like
too but his friend is Adam Strange and I
was like oh she everybody shut the [ __ ]
up champion of Ron what up well can I
give you guys another little I'm about
to spoil this [ __ ] out of season one but
this is what the show really is everyone
thought that this show coming up was
going to be a Superman prequel that's
not what the show is this is an else
world story and I'll tell you the reason
why so everyone thought that it's out of
strange come back in time says brainiacs
coming and I need your help to stop him
because Superman's amazing in about
Episode four if say gets kidnapped by a
man this man knows about Brainiac he
knows about the future he knows about
Superman
Lichter Zod who is who's in a
relationship with sake rescues him with
Adam Strange Adam Strange looks at their
masters we got to kill him right now
whose sake I got this all wrong it's not
Brainiac who came
back it's this guy and General Zod looks
at lights Azad and says hello mother
it's General Zod General Zod came back
in time to Krypton to save Krypton
that's what the show is wait what did
you not know this
ah [ __ ] it you just did a better job of
selling that show than sci-fi did that
whole [ __ ] again but slow yes okay so
here we go
Zod is a hero yes because the thing is
think about General Zod [ __ ] mark would
make up on this show
it's the hero no my god why isn't anyone
doing that but they're doing it he is
because think General Zod is a character
all he's ever wanted is to save Krypton
that's all he's ever fought to please or
he's always been a very honest person he
doesn't see himself as a villain all the
best villains think of themselves as
heroes and Generals odd in this show is
an atom strange never told seg the
Krypton blows up he never told sake that
Krypton has to die for Superman to live
where as General Zod says yes Superman
was my enemy kal-el was my enemy but all
I've ever wanted was to save this planet
and he chose them the humans over us
these people who are obsessed with greed
and hatred all I've ever wanted is to
save our people and Sexy's this man says
yeah he's got a plan he seems this duty
I understand what I cast you number one
Yeah right away I was like yes yes I
believe all whatever you want oh my god
goddamn it you they don't need to spend
any money on ads they just put a camera
on you and go this is what happens this
week here we go
I would totally watch that was
dramatically explained exhale and you
have awesome conversations like you know
jor-el like Zod mentioning that
yes kal-el was an enemy of mine but your
son was my best friend you know and
you've really get into this sort of the
nitty-gritty of those relationships what
comics is all about and so season two is
if season two once again sorry Chloe if
it had a Star Wars style opening crawl
you might have to do that a lot
yeah the first sentence of the Star Wars
opening crawl of Krypton season 2 would
be Zod has won
Zod's defeated Superman Zod is starting
a Kryptonian Empire and that's where we
start with season 2 so really he just
starts season 2 right now if you wanted
to does he not his his pitch is I've
always I've always extended my hand to
kal-el I never took any pleasure in
being his enemy but I just want Krypton
to live that's all I want if kal-el
comes to be then kal-el comes to be but
I just want to save our people and then
you end up with Adam Strange instead of
saying like no but you don't understand
like the great flaw of adam strange's
character is that he can't communicate
the miracle of superman you know but he
can't he to say it's all just numbers
because because adam says trillions of
people will die if this man doesn't
exist but seg just says this is my home
this is my family what and there's a
really brilliant speech and in episode 6
I'm ruining all of this no you're
[ __ ] selling all of this man there's
a difference this it was kind of meta
what we're sake sort of blows up at the
two of them both Zod and a dimension so
says forget about the numbers and it's
really a statement about what the show
is itself is what is the point of all of
this if it just ends in fire and death
you know and that's not what seg feels
but it's what the show is what is the
point of telling the story of this
planet if it doesn't matter and our show
is it does the timeline has changed
that's so [ __ ] metal give it up what
a great explanation oh my god thank you
guys so much
that's amazing
Krypton is apparently the best show that
you're not [ __ ] watching right now
now I know what I'm
with my free time how many episodes in
season one it's ten it's it's a very
very short running shows ten ten
episodes very focused or [ __ ] you had
me at Krypton the the what is it like
entering the very small fraternity and
sorority of folks that have worn the
[ __ ] symbol man it's the most special
thing in the world and I think I think
any actor hopefully when they get a role
like this understands what it means this
isn't like any other job this is your
you're carrying a flag that means so
much to millions of people the whole
world over and when I felt alone when I
was a kid I'd read Superman books and I
always sort of thought if there's anyone
who's gonna care about this it's gonna
be me and and there was a moment in the
first episode of season one where Sega's
past Superman's cape it's kind of like
the Marty McFly photo in Back to the
Future Adam Strange brings it back in
time and says you know if if this cape
disappears Superman's gone and he gives
it to say Clark that's the ticking clock
and so there are walls this show is
amazing man I'm about to cry like all of
this is [ __ ] great it's it's it's a
beautiful thing that I'm a part of and
holding that cape in the solitude I was
literally trembling you know we have the
set of the fortress of solitude and
there I am holding Superman's cape you
know it's you know I you talked about
the romanticism of making films but this
is that be a millions degree I hear on
your planet the S stands for hope indeed
indeed it does you might hear that a few
times throughout the show did they call
it in the real world what do you what do
you call it the Sejal they caught the
glyph in CW world like Supergirl
s is called the glyph they're always
like be careful the glyph don't get
anything on the glyph get your hand off
the [ __ ] lip and the first few times
they said I was like I'm a comic book
guy I don't know what that means but the
glyph I guess the hieroglyph it comes
from or something like that
yeah but if that's how they describe it
court left but it's also called the
sigil the situation cell you know it's I
wanted to say something by the CW guys I
met Grant Gustin my first ever comic-con
and it was a magical moment as I adore
the flash and you know where it were
different network and we're doing
something slightly different and the
cool thing about Krypton is it it's an
else Ward story we get to take a risk
but I I was super jet lag coming up from
London and I woke up about 5:00 in the
morning and I went to the gym in this
hotel in San Diego and it was in Grant
Gustin which was great as the blood
flash you know and the clash and
Superman's grandpa were working out
together yeah it was really cool but I
went over to him and said look if it
wasn't for you guys if it wasn't for the
amazing like you guys have done we
wouldn't be here so thank you for doing
everything you've done so that we could
be here and then the next year at San
Diego I was running to do press and
these massive hotels like the hallways
the size of football fields and he was
running to press harder and depressed
and I thought he's not remember my name
Grant Gustin one of the most beloved TV
stars in America runs all the way from
one end of the hall to the other end of
the hall gives me a huge hug and says
Cameron how is season one man like just
the nicest guy everyone he's been so one
way how fast was he like did it take him
a long time to cover that distance yeah
we're like this yes and also when he
reached you really like let's [ __ ]
race yeah let's go for it
man I this has been wonderful I tell you
man like you've literally sold the
[ __ ] show to people who probably
should have been watching in the first
place but to be fair nobody has
explained it in such a way that made me
go oh I'm [ __ ] stupid for not having
watched that man like that's I'm [ __ ]
in and so season it is really good you
have to [ __ ] say yeah but it is
really I mean [ __ ] the would say it's
fine yeah
the light oh you explained this
described I absolutely am gonna start
watching instantly season two though
where does Lobo come and instantly he
comes in right at the end of episode one
and then episode two is an all Lobos
spectacular and then next week is going
to be one of the most memorable action
scenes in any comic book TV show then
Lobo is the center of it and I really
want you guys to watch it so catch it's
on TV tomorrow it's gonna be really
exciting episode for episode three three
yeah then and hey we've got doomsday
this year we've got brainy why there's
so much more going on man it here's the
thing looking like why aren't they
telling people this hey man
like ain't like it's my like whole thing
to know [ __ ] like this and really dooms
yeah are you sure you're not spoiling
something no no no he's in all the ads
lightener no it's it's them and I hate
they look like him
oh dude who does it looks put in here's
the really cool thing again back to the
practical it's a puppet in motion it's
CGI but in real life it's it's a tool
puppet
they build emotes and breathe and it's
incredible it's so so cool pretty dope
yeah it's awesome
sorry no we we understand the skepticism
about you know show about Superman's
grandfather but we took a lot of risk
with this and we believe in this and
this is something different and if you
give us a chance we feel you won't
regret it
I'm gonna [ __ ] cry give it up my
camera that's beautiful man
[Music]
way to advocate for your [ __ ] art man
you just converted a bunch of people and
[ __ ] alright you know once they got to
season two I'm like there must be doing
something right and some people I know
and trust were like I don't know do I
think you'd like this but [ __ ] it you've
just pushed me over the top
hell yeah we're good we've got a rest of
the show to get to so give it up for
Cameron everybody
excellent job excellent job so weird
that it's like you know I felt like I've
just discovered something and it took
the [ __ ] star of the show to help me
discover it but like [ __ ] whatever
works man [ __ ] it late last few mornings
I've been waking up and there has been
nothing that I'm like oh let me get back
to watching that so it's gonna be
[ __ ] Krypton now that's gonna be
double alright
this is the part of the show folks
really enjoy it's the Q&A part of the
show ladies and gentlemen this is where
we let you folks direct where we're
heading for the rest of the evening we
let Jay see our proprietor here pick
three people from the audience and ask
us questions if your question which has
to be relevant to both me and mark by
the way you know is good enough
you win surprises number one you're
gonna win Nate's poster for this evening
show and it's signed by me and mark and
Nate and whatnot and if you don't win
one of these you can find Nate and buy
one of them later on you can also win
you will also win a pair of 4dx
tickets from Deakin and our good friends
at 40x the folks who are putting
together our 2dx screening and stuff
like that this is for the 4dx theater
that's in LA live but if you haven't
seen a movie in 40 acts [ __ ] you that's
the commercial so we thank them for
these tickets we thank you for our
spider-man 2dx screening that's coming
up and stuff like that so there it is
JC's picked our first person what's your
name young sir my name is Greg Greg Greg
Greg everyone give it up for Greg man oh
before I start I just want to say I love
you guys you guys are my father's day
gift Oh problem but for Father's Day
bought me tickets to see the show and
she said I'm not going
she cuz she looked you guys up yeah I'm
not interested
response I get the same thing for my
[ __ ] what Wow so she goes you go have
fun with your friend go all right so you
guys are my father's day gift so I'm
happy to be some tells me that we're
it's how we may be being cooked I think
like I honestly feel like she's like go
be with mark go talk about Superman
it'll be fine very happy without me
bothering her for a couple hours so
she's like so you think your wife is not
as happy just not having you bother I
what I'm saying is I think my wife is
[ __ ] cheating on me while I think
this show she's never once come to one
of these [ __ ] shows once she came
once it was anyway back to you my main
question is now that Disney has
purchased Fox into the mic it we're a
club sorry sorry now the Disney's
purchased Fox and I'm sure everybody's
asked about x-men and stuff like that
but how would you bring closer closer
sorry sorry what's your pitch of
bringing in Fantastic Four into the MCU
if we were all lucky and they asked you
two guys to go into the pitch room and
say how would you bring in Fantastic
Four into MCU what would be your pitch
[ __ ] good I like this you go first
because you're way more inventive wait a
minute okay unless you guys are already
working on that believe me if I was I'd
be dropping hints like I'd be all for
that yeah I'm stretching
that would not leave me yeah no it's
there there believe me they we're not
that good I I think I would do a period
thing I think I would do like the right
stuff I think you do it like 60s you
know and like wait why didn't we all
hear about him like before you got to
bring them into the curve of Kerrville
current marvel curtain current Marvel
continuity I mean how do you not hear
about [ __ ] a man that stretches a
lady that's invisible if you do it like
First Avenger if you do it like you most
of the movies in the 60s they go off to
[ __ ] space and then they don't come
back until 2021 that's how you do it
that's how you do it that's good just
you can get that [ __ ] like the John
Glenn the the awesomeness of the right
stuff and like no we're sending four men
into space for three men and a lady into
space and you can also get the escape
from the Planet of the Apes kind of like
who are these strange visitors who've
arrived in our time what did we the
missing ship yeah it's like what did
what did they what did the world miss
them and what did they miss by being
gone from the world and like coming back
and I went to integrate into society as
just [ __ ] people who've been missing
for 40 years and who were super [ __ ]
weird now that they're back I think that
there's there's there's a ton of like
that's a lot of character you get to
play with it in and amongst all of the
[ __ ] insane awesomeness that you'll
get out of Fantastic Four you know and
maybe doom has been here the whole time
like maybe Doom has become like Elon
Musk in in their absence and like put
like older like you can [ __ ] you know
he could cast you could cast Keanu
Reeves as like Victor Von Doom last week
the internet seems to feel he needs to
play Marc Spector Moon Knight which I
also agree with as well
that we could you imagine if he was
playing moon night I thought you could
cast Keanu was a silver surfer you get
some point break Point Break references
oh yeah that's that's so that's my tape
I go 60s they that's so brilliant I was
gonna be like multiverse I like yours so
much more I cannot top it I don't even
have an original idea to get close let's
see what are they have they set us up an
end game and [ __ ] was there set up there
because that's what I would look for the
way to fit it into what's already there
but you found a way more clever things
unless the end of far from home is Peter
Parker gets a job at that Baxter
building I'm clutching your heart it's
like oh my god well here's the I don't I
really don't have a better picture than
his his was [ __ ] absolutely amazing
but here's my question is do you think
they're even close to referencing
fantastic for you we know they've said
they're not even close I heard that
rumor 20:22 would be when they did the
movie yeah 2022 is like they're looking
at some casting Liam Hemsworth is
rumored for Human Torch what you're
fired you're hired
that's the [ __ ] news that's John
Krasinski and Emmeline wait wait go
slower [ __ ] sorry it's not too fast I'm
already about to come go slow further
with Liam Liam Hendriks has been and
this is all internet rumor so grain of
salt you know what the internet rumors
are as good as factors on concern
make me happy so Liam Hemsworth has been
talked about as human torch okay as one
possible like I there's rumor that he's
been talked to rumor I guess the rock
posted stuff on Twitter that he had a
meeting with Kevin Feige so rumor is he
might be the voice of
the thing because if the things on cgi
once again once again grain of salt and
it is a bit of typecasting yeah whatever
starring the rock as the guy made of
orange rock and also grain of salt
possible another reference was John
Krasinski and Emily Blunt as Reed
Richards and Sue Storm
that's [ __ ] adorable man because good
they're married in real life and both
both were slated to be in the MCU John
Krasinski as as Captain America he even
wore the suit in her audition why is
believe what you're fired again I spend
a lot of time on the internet so I'm
gonna go [ __ ] his wife now
[Applause]
I'm gonna show her that part on YouTube
net weight Krasinski was the war he wore
the Captain America seat he had an
audition and Emily Blunt was the
original Black Widow but she had
scheduling conflicts wait what yes
who said many interviews slow I read a
lot of Internet that is [ __ ] I am a
teacher and I'm on summer break so well
so let's do the math this must have been
after that she was Scarlett Johansson
was technically the second choice it was
Emily Blunt was the first one but off of
Iron Man Iron Man 2 they were originally
one in Emily Blunt but she has all of
the Devil Wears probably like what was
Emily Blunt coming off of that they were
like she could be I think the the
Gulliver movie or she was like the
little was that somebody knows what was
it there you go
she's hasn't got real apples movie like
something cheap like she had another it
was Devil Wears Prada but she was Black
Widow and Scarlett Johansson was second
choice so these are two people you say
it twice in somewhere Scarlett
Johansson's like I heard you the first
time [ __ ] these are two people
that have Marvel has wanted they were
almost there dear Kevin Feige killed
Greg's I yeah I've read a lot of
interviews so so but I that's one of the
rumors was the having those guys in
there so as well we tell you something
if your question was good enough got
great answer out of him the dish that
you just gave us which apparently others
knew but I didn't and I'm gonna treat
like nobody's known until tonight I
guarantee I [ __ ] read the internet
after the show they pull the weirdest
things to be like this is news
someone's gonna [ __ ] make that news
someone's gonna be like did you know
that Krasinski and [ __ ] and Emily
Blunt were almost these two characters
so according to Greg on the latest fad
hey here on fire tonight
oh my gosh there's just a little bit of
a challenge you're like oh no
[ __ ] fire that was awesome great
question great stuff give it up for Greg
he won by the way real quick I'm an avid
fan last week you guys were coming up
with dead actors who could play MC you
characters that have him in cast yet my
buddy at a bar before I came the show
came with a perfect one go Robert Shaw
Quint from Jaws yes as Kraven the hunter
oh that's my buddy right there who came
up with it that's great man that is
[ __ ] up Shaw is Craven oh well yeah
big-game hunter has not yeah can you get
him to I mean he's not alive it but good
we're gonna need a bigger boat did an
MCU just like I said throw away I have
to tag up on that one thanks Greg hey
what's your name I'm Katie
what is it Katie what do you got for us
Katie okay so my question is more
focused on the Disney Plus shows that
are gonna be coming out specifically the
Loki one um I don't know if any this
might be very controversial but I feel
kind of fatigued after all the heel
turns that Loki has done in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so what I was
wondering is it's kind of a question and
like sub Part B question what kind of
stories do you feel like would be
interesting to get people who are maybe
a little fatigued back on the Loki train
and like what would be a good goal for
Loki to like get onto a path for
whatever arc because I kind of feel like
when I think of a goal I just kind of
think oh like why would Loki care about
blah blah blah I mean I think the
interesting thing to do and I think the
show I don't know if they announced it
if it's just what it's going to be but
Loki with the tesseract kind of quantum
leaping his way
kind of through like an endgame yeah and
I want see is that with a low key from
endgame is going like I think it's from
there are you [ __ ] me they set up a
TV show in the movie they could have if
they wanted to it's it's it's on the
buffet table if they want to pick it up
that would be so smart cuz did anybody
follow where that low key went it just
disappears could they be 2012 low key
just coming off of first Avengers and so
like what does he really care about I
don't know
was is somebody smarter than us did
somebody do an internet deep dive on
this Greg what do you know we got fired
[Applause]
I'm going out oh my god that's
hysterical it would be interesting
though if you could if you can do you
could do 2012 Loki who encounters 2019
Loki like the Loki who's made the turn
the Loki's been through it all with his
brother the post ragnarök loki who laid
his life on the line for his brother
there's totally a way in which you could
I mean a buddy cop show a buddy cop
quantumly put to Loki's would be kind of
[ __ ] amazing okay fire tonight yeah
you're fired
yeah oh my god twice to Tom Hiddleston
man
two times Abelson and it's a limited
series right yeah yeah I bet you mana
man I guess I'm not maybe other people
smarter than me have seen this already
because when you said it it felt like
you knew something but that Loki that
disappeared an end game could be the
Loki that the whole [ __ ] series is
predicated on and thereby this would be
a sequel series to [ __ ] one of the
biggest well the movie that's about to
be the biggest movie of all time
it's unheralded I've never really done
that before that's [ __ ] dope do you
think they knew that going in that they
were creating them back to our TV series
which sounds sexier than I meant it but
you know what I mean
I think so I think so I mean no smart
because they denounced the TV show
months before and game came out you're
right yeah I like the still that they
put out which I guess was created or
whatever [ __ ] of him in front of a
marquee that had jaws on it because it
instantly said does my [ __ ] gonna
travel through time and I'm like oh I'll
[ __ ] watch that like if that's the
Loki show that's how they get me if I
didn't I don't quite have the Loki
fatigue that some first world people do
but I I that made me more interested
once I saw that image cuz I was like oh
that's [ __ ] clever like you can take
him away from all those characters that
we would be like why isn't he hanging
out with these cats if he's [ __ ] lost
in time and you could sprinkle in Marvel
Universe which now it's coming from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe of you damn
Skippy they're gonna lay stuff in
I'm sure he'll run into our to start
mm-hmm yeah I was I was very encouraged
by that one [ __ ] picture and not like
I was discouraged by a Loki show I was
like oh I'll watch it but more in a
sense of like I'll do watch anything
they what would they make but when I saw
that image I was like it's [ __ ]
clever but now if it's not your show
like if it's not to Tom it'll since
[ __ ] fighting each other
and getting along like I'll be really
disappointed like twice the Tom is like
that's all the show I don't have a
pitchman once again [ __ ] he's way
more creative than me I don't know that
I don't know that I could be more
creative than that but that was a great
question and it do you answered it
didn't you one time I wrapped up and
Mark was like you didn't let me answer
that was a great answer you win the
[ __ ] poser call okay
well God Katie
and for that fire Greg joke well done
yes here we go what's your name captain
hi I'm Giovanni Giovanni won't give it
up for Giovanni ah buongiorno Giovanni
what can we do you for cab so I've been
listening to this show since it was long
form interview and since you started
this format I've been thinking like what
I want to say and I thought like I've
got like hours of things I could say to
both you but I'm not going to do that
because I listen to the people who talk
for hours but I just want to say that
every week I listen to this show that
you guys do it and every week you guys
make me feel like we're friends in real
life so thank you so much thank you for
that my question is is taking it back to
a somewhat talked about character named
Batman yeah what what - you guys are the
defining characteristics of Batman the
thing that makes him your Batman and
where do you feel that was best
represented on the big screen oh well
what's best representative Batman for me
it's the sad the sad little kid who just
swears that this will never happen to
anyone again that's at the root of every
one of those stories when he's pounding
the [ __ ] out of somebody when he's
putting the Joker away for the gazillion
of time at the root of it is this can't
happen again and it's heartbreaking the
characters so [ __ ] like tragic
because he can't stop it
like the city's bleeding from every
place and he's got a box of band-aids
but he the child in him is desperate to
make it right and only a child like
steeped in [ __ ] grief like I've lost
my parents makes this ridiculous vow of
like this will never happen again a
realist would never think that and if
you've lost your parents to violence I'm
sure you've become a realist [ __ ]
quick but what's wonderful about that
story is instead of going down the way
of grief he turned it into heroism now
you know we put it through a postmodern
filter and we're like he's [ __ ] crazy
but it really was such a noble and still
is such a noble idea
the simple truth of I I this is the most
horrible thing that ever happened to me
and it will never happen to anyone else
again so when you see him as an adult
then I love in the comics I wrote it
into some of the stuff I wrote
interacting with kids it's always really
special because it's like that's why he
wears that [ __ ] suit he was robbed of
a [ __ ] child that he was robbed that
the rest of his [ __ ] life and it's
one thing to not want people to come to
harm but it's especially like whoever's
come to harm isn't just like some victim
that's somebody's mom that's somebody's
dad the crime is revisited upon him time
and time again that [ __ ] is so
deliciously emo that [ __ ] I love with
it as I talk about it I'm like I get
goosebumps cuz I'm like [ __ ] that's so
good that's such good writing and it
wasn't one person that character that we
all know and love has been created by a
vast many amount of writers who have
added these wonderful flourishes that
made him what it was closest I think
they ever got in a movie well let's just
do him through the years not the black
and white shorts not Adam West's Batman
although I love that Batman but you know
it's it was Batman of its era but it
wasn't like yours they rarely it was
definitely my first Batman but it wasn't
it's not the Batman you think of his
tragic like if that Batman if his
parents were killed he didn't seem to
remember you know it wasn't like I must
stop this who said Robin let's do it cuz
it's fun like you know which was great
for its time and when I was a kid that's
what I loved I didn't need to paint
those of that character that came later
on when I grew up and somebody said you
don't know the [ __ ] story of Batman's
parents and stuff I think it was Brawley
Walter Flanagan and [ __ ] when I handed
him the report that I wrote for on
Batman in high school my senior high
school and I told Walter oh I know a
little bit about Batman I wrote this
report you want to read it and he was
like no I was like bringing it anyway
and so I brought it in he read it and he
came in the next day he's like you know
anything
Batman you talk about aunt Harriet
that's a character from the TV show you
know anything about his parents in here
I was like what do you mean what I mean
had parents because yeah and they were
[ __ ] killed like really shitty about
it and I was like oh I'm sorry I didn't
know as if he was a real person in [ __ ]
but he started bringing me in where
suddenly he was like you know anything
about Batman he gave me the Dark Knight
Returns that [ __ ] changed everything
so not Adam West Batman although I do
deeply loved that and that was my first
Batman I remember when Tim Burton's
Batman came out we were like this shit's
so dark and now when you watch it today
it seems like Adam West's Batman because
it's not really that dark and also it's
just like you know our Batman in the
comics like can kill you [ __ ] 16
different ways 26 60 different ways with
just his bare hands and [ __ ] like that
living weapon he's trained himself and
like there's that fantasy part of the of
the character that's fun as well not
only like are my parents killed but
everyone's gonna [ __ ] pay for that
and he's gonna beat them up like that's
power fantasy that's fun as well but the
what was I saying right before a power
fantasy god it was good and I'm about to
lose it cuz I'm a STONER
Tim Burton I being Adam West oh thank
you
I was about to [ __ ] on the movie a
little bit that character who's honed
himself to physical perfection and [ __ ]
like that is presented to us in what we
considered at the time to be the best
rendition of the Dark Knight as a guy
who could only fight like this
but we didn't care because it was like
oh this is so [ __ ] close
but that didn't capture the essence that
care we're not that the Pecos of the
character the parts that I look for none
of them really did like not not Michael
Keaton not Val Kilmer not George Clooney
and not by any fault of their own you
know they played with the aspect of like
his parents are dead ain't it sad but
you know it was more about like looking
a batwing look at a [ __ ] Joker [ __ ]
the pathos so Chris Nolan's stuff I
guess you know in Batman Begins there's
a bit of it maybe that's as close as it
gets the the second one Dark Knight they
don't do is pass so much and it's more
about like I'm fighting my Dark Mirror
and then the third one not really as
well
then we're into Batman V Superman then
that really doesn't capture the [ __ ]
paint those of like my parents died
although but we certainly know one of
their names that's for sure but still
movies well done and that's not mention
on movies well done but it's alright to
be honest I think the cartoons have come
closer to capturing the essence of what
it is like Batman the the mask of the
phantasm probably a lot closer what else
has come closer you know what doc didn't
jump on your thing go what the the
commercial for the Arkham City yeah
video game by our guy friend at 2
million mill studios but it starts with
like the the young it's all in Bruce
Wayne's eyes hands he's this is hands
down one of the greatest Batman films
ever made and it's a 30-second
commercial for a video game but I'm not
being facetious when you watch this it
encapsulates the [ __ ] journey and it
makes you weep i we blew it for so long
and then we like I was like this whoever
made this is [ __ ] genius and yeah I
was like this kid's got a big future
ahead of him and [ __ ] like that and he
wrote to me is like hi my name's Tim
Miller like because I was talking about
Deadpool at the time and he's like uh
not only did i do Deadpool but I also
did that
Batman video game that you guys talked
about in your show and [ __ ] love so
much and I thank you for pointing me out
as a young up-and-coming kid but I'm 55
years old but that [ __ ] commercial
life it's what is it is it for Arkham
which arcade game Arkham City origins is
it and it's got like the voice over the
letter from his dad which is like no no
that's not the one I'm talking because
I'm jumping on you because that one is
like you know dear Bruce I know as you
get older you're going to have like you
know childhood dalliance --is you're
going to want to spend your money in
wrong ways you're gonna want to stay out
too late at night you're gonna do damage
to your bodies that you can't cause in
imagery from the letter when it's it's
spent too much money you're in the
[ __ ] Batcave like you're gonna want
to be out too late at night it's [ __ ]
Batman like it's all the things a father
hopes his son doesn't do is exactly what
his son is doing but in fundamentally a
different way than his father expected
it's it's the operatic and it's just a
perfect little like crystalline piece of
this is what this life is like that is
good the one I was referring to was I
don't know which game it is example of
the games origins so it shows it's the
camera is fixed on and I guess they
would call what a cutscene in a video
game or something cameras fixed on the
face of young Bruce Wayne and clearly
he's standing between his parents but
you're close on him so you get the
impression their bodies they're his
hands I think if I remember correctly
are in the up position meaning like he's
being escorted and it's his face is pure
joy and it's for about two seconds at
the beginning of this commercial and
it's the most valuable piece of real
estate that two seconds because it sets
the tone just like this kids happy and
then you hear the [ __ ] gunshot and
I'm gonna cry talking about and you see
the flash and his fit and it's all kind
of slow-mo and his face drops it goes
from the joy the elation the happiness
the contended childhood to what the [ __ ]
just happened and they used the bang of
the gun to jump ahead in his life and
they do it about five times or something
so the first one he's the boy who just
watched his parents
get killed and then they go bang and
they jump ahead to the boy at his
parents funeral with rain coming down
and [ __ ] umbrella and [ __ ] like that
then bang the boy at private school
who's getting into fights and [ __ ] like
that then bang the young man who goes
off and learns to train to become Batman
and then BAM like [ __ ] him as The
Dark Knight and [ __ ] punching for the
first time so it shows you the entire
painful [ __ ] journey of that
character to the place where you see
this dude in this outfit about to punch
somebody you know go like this makes
absolute [ __ ] sense like that's what
I would do you know
oh it's incredibly [ __ ] moving Jim
Miller didn't need a fantastic [ __ ]
job with it that is that may be the
closest thing to what I'm talking about
the essence of [ __ ] Batman that I
respond to you can find it online I
forget exactly what it's called but oh
it's [ __ ] breathtaking for me Batman
heroism is is choice right like you're
choosing to do a thing heroism doesn't
happen by accident it doesn't happen
just oh I happen to be there you're
choosing to do something that ordinary
people won't choose and the choice that
Bruce Wayne makes is he forgoes any
attempt at happiness for the salvation
of Gotham City and it's a choice that
will never fundamentally pay out but
every time you see him I mean and the
Nolan movies get at this I think the
best of the there's Rachel Dawes she's
the girl I'm in love with I can never be
with her and every time he's faced with
I could save her or save the city he
will choose the city and so watching the
ongoing tragedy of this man who's earned
everything he could possibly ever want
but chooses to not have it because my
city needs me and he doesn't want to
fail a city like its that by the way the
city took everything from him totally
like the city has never earned that love
but he gives it every day every night
and without blinking without flinching
at all which is he's not real and I get
so emotional
oh my god he's such a good man you know
getting like and when he lets Rachel die
spoilers it's it's uh that is the the
apotheosis of that choice of that desire
to forgo any personal happiness for the
mission that to me is one enemies it is
a little bit the mark of slight insanity
slight you know there's a psychopathy
going on with Bruce Wayne but even
through it all that choice for him is
crystal clear and and that's that's the
heartbreaking part for me about it this
is so funny because we can justify like
in this room nobody like nobody
questions when you go like if that's
what happened like I could see myself
doing that like everyone's like yeah
right at me too if you went out to a
real barn a man if your parents got
killed do you think you'd be Batman's
like my parents did get killed and I
killed them shut the [ __ ] up and leave a
long by the way I'm Batman
[Laughter]
which is part of the reason why I think
you know many of us were a little chafed
by the end of Dark Knight Rises by the
way a Batman it's so brilliant and
that's but doctor I am Batman because
Batman would never make the choice for
happiness like the Batman that we know
and love would never choose to like sip
cappuccino in some Italian veranda when
Gotham is still [ __ ] Gotham you know
it's which as a purist I should have
felt that rage and if you go back and
listen like the podcast that did an
episode of Smaug has emotional years ago
when Dark Knight came out and I got real
crazy emotion I saw it like three times
in 24 hours so I could do the movie from
memory really well and [ __ ] but I was I
brought up [ __ ] what was the point you
were just talking about the ending of
Dark Knight Rises
as a Batman purist I should be like come
on he would never [ __ ] quit the city
for [ __ ] any woman let alone Catwoman
a [ __ ] like that or anybody he's
committed to the [ __ ] city but as I
told Mosers a telex Cabos the story I
was like and this guy he's fly
this [ __ ] bomb out to the ocean and
[ __ ] like that
and he knows he's gonna [ __ ] die and
like I was I was ok with that because he
earned it man like [ __ ] but then when
he showed up at the end and he was alive
like I was so happy for him because he
earned that too and so he handled that
material in such a way where me as a
Batman person but it should have been
like [ __ ] that like I bought it I'm like
he's allowed to rest man mark for him
are you reading the comics currently the
Tom King run would you do I'm sorry
they're they're put there playing with
that exact idea that you're talking
about it's really the comics are great
Tom the King he's the one that he's
doing he started with restore miracles
yes yep he did he's either one that
wrote the ace the bat-hound story I
don't know anyone remember that story
came out of what Batman book it was his
back good dog yes yes that was him one
of the greatest if you've never read
this story is when the greatest Batman
stories ever told it's not really about
Batman although of course it's all about
Batman about Alfred but it's about
Alfred more and really it's about ace
the bat-hound
and it's a [ __ ] reinvention that like
as a light I'm gonna get [ __ ] I'm too
emotional as a rescue dog owner it
[ __ ] kills you like at your art
because the story ace the bat-hound as
we all know it's [ __ ] Batman's dog
and sometimes wears the mask and the
cape and [ __ ] like that and he's that
various incarnations throughout Batman's
history this incarnation I hope it's Tom
King who wrote it but if not whoever
wrote is [ __ ] genius but I'm pretty
sure it is dunking the story begins with
the the dog is one of the Joker's
hence painted up like you know [ __ ]
like a hedge dog and [ __ ] like that
as a wild as you do as you do as a wild
animal and they cut to him like later on
if I remember correctly Batman defeats
Joker whatever but they find this pit
where there's this vicious [ __ ] dog
with blood all over him and dead dogs
surrounding him
and I think the line was something like
the Joker just left the Meijer all to
die and he's the last dog standing so
the implication is this [ __ ] dog is
crazy broken and should be destroyed
because he killed all these other
[ __ ] dogs and Batman is a Batman who
takes him home
yeah Batman brings him back and Alfred
winds up slowly training him and it's a
beautiful [ __ ] story about like PTSD
about like surviving oh I'm like it's so
well-written very little dialogue not
long it's not like 22-page isn't you but
that was I wrote a story for the
Detective Comics 1000 about Batman that
a lot of people thank god [ __ ] liked
and we're like you made up for making
him piss his pants you [ __ ] jerk so
people like that story they I owe that
story to to that story because that was
my model I read that and I was like if I
could tell a [ __ ] concise wonderful
Batman story that adds a little bit to
the mythos and is like moving and hits
you right in the right places [ __ ] if I
could do it like that
that was my model so I like if hopefully
he's the right guy we're blowing the
right car somewhere top gigs like I
didn't write that [ __ ] it's definitely
in the last because I remember it ends
with Christmas Day and Batman gives out
for the gift he goes oh you know Alfred
don't worry about it you didn't get me
anything and that's what I took away
from it he's like yeah you know master
Bruce I didn't get you anything that's
the thing he raised that dog like Alfred
gave him the best yes yes oh my god it's
it's a wonderful [ __ ] story did you
answer I did answer did I answer you did
that was a great question you want a
poster anyone daggits give it up for
everybody
[Applause]
how nice like it's it felt like like
being in a marriage and I don't want
this to reflect on my wife because she's
way cool but it felt like being in a
marriage and like doing something you
haven't done a long time like we went to
the roller rink like something we did
like when we were kids to talk about
Batman on the show Batman Beyond and
[ __ ] like that
it was nice to kind of roll around in
the warm embrace of the character again
thank you for that that was really
really sweet we got no more show left to
do ladies gentlemen you have a good time
this evening I can't thank you enough
for being here don't forget Nate has his
prints if you want to buy print from
Nate he also has these fine fat man
beyond pins and whatnot if you want to
get one from him find him after the show
but that show which this show doesn't
exist without the guy standing to my
left give it up for the great Mark
Bernardo and that is fat man I'm back
fat man beyond for this week I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Marvin Arjuna next time same
bat time same bat Channel SModcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith for the
good of all Krieger night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you